So this is what had to say about Socialists.
It might be sad,
however,
that even if the theoretical oriented book trained socialist is not a working
man himself,
at least he has actually created by a love of the working class he's endeavoring
to shed is bourgeois status and fight on the side of the proletariat.
Obviously that must be his motive,
but is it
sometimes I look at the socialist,
the intellectual tract writing type of socialist with his pullover because fuzzy
hair and his Marxist quotation and wonder what the devil is.
Motive really is.
It's really difficult to believe that it's a love of anybody,
especially if the working class from whom he is of all people,
the furthest removed.
The truth is that too many people calling them socialists revolution does not
mean a movement of the masses with which they hope to associate themselves.
It means instead of set of reforms which we the clever ones are going to impose
on them the lower orders.
On the other hand,
it would be a mistake to regard the book train socialist as a bloodless
creature,
entirely incapable of emotion,
though seldom giving much evidence of affection for the exploited
is perfectly capable of displaying hatred,
sort of queer theoretical in vacuum.
Oh,
hatred against the explorers.
Hence the grand old social sport of denouncing the bourgeoisie.
It is strange how easily almost any socialist writer can lash himself into
frenzies of rage against the class too,
which by birth or by adoption,
he himself almost invariably belongs.
Oh,
I worked for the NDP when I was a kid and I had privileged access to the
leadership for provincially and federally for reasons that I won't go into.
And I thought that
many of them were honorable people who were really striving to give the working
class of voice.
And I believe that the working class needs a voice,
a political voice for obvious reasons.
Um,
I think the Democrats in the United States have made an absolutely dreadful
abysmal mistake replacing their working class,
political ethos with identity politics.
We're going to talk about that.
And,
uh,
and I don't think the situation has changed that much.
I think one of the things that's happened in the United States is that
world stability and peace in some ways has been purchased at the expense of
North American working class wellbeing now because the Chinese have got rich
compared to 30 years ago,
40 years ago,
50 years ago,
the,
the Indians have gotten rich again,
same comparison basis.
There's more middle class people in India now than there are on the United
States.
Um,
the trade arrangements that have been in North America allowed for the rise of
middle classes globally at the same time,
they opened up the working class in North America to competition from those low
wage sources.
And maybe that's a good deal.
It's hard to say,
right,
because it's not such a bad thing that the Chinese aren't starving and it's not
such a bad thing that the Indians aren't starving and that those societies are
transforming themselves actually into communities that are quite wealthy.
It's like hooray for that.
It's an absolutely miraculous transformation.
It's the most rapid growth of human wealth in the history of humanity.
So we should be pretty happy about that,
but we should also remember at least to some degree who's paid the price for it
and so as far as I'm concerned,
the working class needs a voice
and
it isn't obvious that they have one at the moment.
Having said that,
however,
it isn't obvious to me at all
that the people who purport to stand for the working class actually do so or
that if they do so that the reason they do so is because they're all
compassionate and sympathetic and loving and kind and St.
Like I'm more convinced by Orwell's argument.
So back to the NDP,
the people I met at the leadership level,
a lot of them I had a fair bit of admiration for,
but as I worked with the party over about a five year period,
there's this contradiction that Cape kept emerging for me and that was that I
didn't really like the low level party functionary activist types.
Like they just weren't personally appealing to me.
They seem peevish and resentful.
And then at the same time I was going to college,
I was about 17.
I got elected to the Senate on the College Board of Governors and at that time
Alberta was conservative politically,
right?
It still is of course,
but they.
It was part of the progressive conservative
empire because they ruled Alberta forever and all the board of governor members
were basically nominees,
right?
They were conservative nominees,
so these were conservative people and I was an NDP member and I thought and I'd
worked for small businessman to who weren't NDP.
They were.
They were conserved.
It never figured that out,
but I'll tell you about that in a minute,
but I had a bad case of cognitive dissonance because actually turned out that I
admired the people on the board of governors and they were mostly.
It was in grand prairie.
It's not a very big place and it's not very old.
And so if you were reasonably successful in grand prairie,
the probability that you inherited your money from the aristocrat aristocracy
was like zero because there wasn't one.
Right.
The whole damn town was 50 years old.
So if you had any influencer or wealth,
you are a small businessman,
small to middle sized businessmen,
and you'd
you knew what you were doing.
And I actually admired these people.
I thought,
well that's not very good.
I mire them and I don't share their political views.
And then there's these other people with whom I hypothetically share political
views and I don't admire them at all.
What's going on?
And then I read road to Wigan pier and I thought,
oh,
that's it.
They don't like the poor.
They just hate the rich.
It's not the same thing.
It's not the same set of motivations.
And so let's say that you're a postmodernist and you privileged compassion for
the oppressed.
Think,
well,
what are you pushed to the margins?
Well,
what are you doing with all your hatred and resentment and you're evil.
It's like you don't have any of that.
That's a bad theory.
That's a really bad theory.
Okay,
so fine.
So you can say,
well yeah,
you can say that,
but I don't buy it.
I still think that the people who stand to speak for the oppressed are in fact
motivated by empathy and sympathy.
Their hearts are in the right place.
See,
I don't really buy that either because I don't really think generally speaking
that it's a credible claim for someone to make that their heart is in the right
place.
Now you can ask that of yourself and if you think your heart is in the right
place,
well more power to you.
You know,
I,
I can't see the halo from here.
However,
and so given that you're just as malevolent as your neighbor or maybe even more
so and that that's actually pretty malevolent given the intrinsic nature of
human beings.
I can't help but wonder what you're doing with all those traits that you're not
admitting to,
but you can.
You could even object.
Well,
you know,
that's a pretty pessimistic view of humankind.
It's not by the way,
it's just not naive,
but anyways,
you could object that and you can say no.
Actually,
the weight of moral authority is in fact on the left,
even the radical left with those who identify with the oppressed and who are
working to better their conditions.
Okay,
fair enough.
So then let's say,
well,
let's give those people some power and if they're actually motivated by
compassion and empathy and desire for the working class,
if you give them power and you give their ideas power,
then as those ideas unfold in real time,
you're going to find out like,
did things get better for the working class,
let's say?
Or did they get worse?
Because we could.
We could consider that like an experiment.
We could consider the outcome proof.
I don't know what else you would do.
I don't know how else you would.
You would come to your decision because it's just theory until you see it
happen.